[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la chance de sa vie
ce soir tout le public a mis des
perruques blondes mois sans rigoler avec
la teinture cammas on dirait on l'a tous
connus c'est quoi on dirait aziz le prof
de d'aquagym on est où là
alors là là je vais te dire la tuer dans
les coulisses de l'émission de téloche
mais c'est là que tout se passe on est à
l'antenne oui on a lancé serge aubin on
est en direct grave a dit de moi que je
manie magnum été super tu vas te mettre
là je vais peut-être là je vais enlever
attend d'eux ont d'abord je veux te dire
une chose oui ça prend la chaux ou là
sur le plateau déjà où on est dans le
couloir là tu es dans le plateau c'est
le prouve dans sa première c'est à dire
que les gens se sont évanouis ça parce
que c'est la première fois que je rentre
sur un de tes plateau et il n'y a pas
d'ambiance
l'avocat
[Applaudissements]
saleh et jouir c'est la première fois
qu'un invité vient pour un livre que
j'ai lu le livre
[Applaudissements]
et
petit intermède divertissement au tour
de magie c'est parti c'est parti je vais
vous demander n'aura de choisir une
carte je ne veux pas la boire je ne la
connais pas je ne veux pas en entendre
parler
montrer leurs travaux à me montrer la
voa me montrer cette carte que je vais
essayer de retrouver tout de suite rom
était là dans le paquet je vais vous
demander s'il vous plaît de mélanger
[Rires]
je demande à monsieur semoun de coupe
est à mon avis un truc à vous est
toujours étonnant les magiciens les ai
coupés bombe à la basse et j'espère que
je vais la trouver
ce n'est pas cette carte je le sais je
vais peut-être laissé celle-ci peut-être
en aura besoin
ça n'est pas celle ci ça n'est pas celle
ci et là je vais demander à cyril
hanouna de retourner cette car si c'est
celle ci s'est alors si c'est ça là pour
le dire mais si c'est ça aussi c'est
celle là moi je sois
[Applaudissements]
on soir merci d'être là en tout cas
merci beaucoup merci merci vous êtes
venu en soit si vous souhaitez rester
dans l'anonymat
oui voilà j'ai pas et donc vous venez
nous voir monsieur paraît que vous avez
la phobie des filles décident des fruits
secs
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]